cinq cent vingt mille tonnes de déchets
sauvages ont été jetés en france en 2018
c'est une estimation de l'omg geste
propre qui fait froid dans le dos
pourtant dès les années 70 les décharges
sauvages étaient déjà dénoncé
aujourd'hui dans notre région il suffit
d'ouvrir les yeux en se promenant des
détritus sont en trouve partout
aucune ville aucun axe routier aucun
cours d'eau
aucune plage n'y échappe les décharges
sauvages prospérer en toute impunité
afin d'éviter les frais de déchetteries
les ordures sont jetés en pleine nature
conséquence pollution visuelle mais
aussi pollutions des nappes phréatiques
et des cours d'eau en 1970 ce chercheur
reprocher aux pouvoirs publics leur
inaction face à ce fléau
je pense que un très gros effort doit
être fait au niveau de l'information du
public et c'est le seul moyen finalement
pour que les mesures nécessaires soient
prises il faut qu'il y ait un
contrepoids à l'inertie de ce qui est
fait jusque-là l'inertie du aux intérêts
privés et comme gouverner c'est prévoir
on peut espérer que les mesures seront
prises à temps les initiatives pour
supprimer ces décharges sont d'abord
locale des bénévoles des militants
écologistes mais aussi certains maires
comme celui de cormeilles-en-parisis en
1972 nous avions cette lèpre ici depuis
de nombreuses années quelque chose
d'absolument ahurissant une véritable
décharge sauvage toute la zone urbanisée
dans ce sens nous sommes limitrophes
venait déposer là c'est sale le mot
environnement étant lâché prenant de
plus en plus de signification
ça nous a incités à prendre le taureau
par les cornes et a lancé cette grande
opération face à ces mobilisations
le ministre de l'environnement de
l'époque robert poujade prend les
premières mesures en 1971 avec la
circulaire qui polluent peu l'ancêtre du
pollueur payeur
les décharges sauvages était alors dans
le viseur j'ai demandé moi-même que les
abandonne
en dehors des décharges soient
sévèrement punis est ce que les français
savent bien il faut peut-être leur dire
qu'aujourd'hui il a en coûte de 80 à 160
francs
si l'on abandonne un objet en dehors
d'une décharge que si ça se fait avec
une voiture ça coûte 1000 francs plus de
quarante ans plus tard le dossier des
décharges sauvages est encore sur le
bureau du ministre de l'écologie pour le
secteur du bâtiment d'où vient une
grande partie des dépôts sauvages
un observatoire national des déchets du
btp sera opérationnel en 2020
[Musique]